while you're watching the game they are
watching the day
welcome to Baywatch hey you people with
lifeguards not believe you people oh you
can say that you're Japan I don't come
on brother why did you eat the cookies
running in ready to do this hell yeah
whoa whoa are you wearing freedom that's
desecration our team is the elite of the
elite with the heart soul of this very
Beach
we protect when other people don't want
to protect and we go above and beyond
[Music]
he warned me he can have me some others
we're staring into the abyss here City
Council's already cut our funding stick
to uh restore the Baywatch brand thank
you anyway
I'm Matt Brody Grady for duty please
it's a Sakai bit I feel look at my face
I'm trying but it's so close to your
boob this is a guy you think it's a good
PR opportunity for ya it's reckless with
two gold medals I mean gold medals do
you have probably Bureau we got a dead
body on our Beach that's not our song my
gut says there's the bad [ __ ] going on
over there at my ball say we need to
check it out eyeball day thinking he's
right what's your ball sound like
three-year-old girl I don't know man
that's how they talk but they're wise
welcome to Baywatch
[Music]
what are you having so far I'd actually
fine honey oh ma you see it too
you turn the canals into the dam x-games
yeah that's cuz we were in lifeguard
pursuit that no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit how do I explain this so that
you people understand you people you
people oh you don't get to say that
you're just right on come on
[Music]
you